il manque toujours autant de la commune
elle a quitté son travail parce que
c'est pas moi qui l'aï fait
elle a appelé à travailler même on
apprend aussi que la grosse pèse comme
un militaire la plus importante de sa
vie
ce faire pour le moment ces travaux
non oui ça marche
c'est passé ça fait peur
dernier
du public
je crois que je suis
ce programme est chargé et le poirier
mon fils et moi qui décide alors on
prend tous les tableaux avec le réseau
des mères cette série
l'écossais s'il veut bien l'avouer
elle s'est rappelée moins de déchets
en présence de m
en tout cas c'est vraiment bon c'est
quoi la science
elle peut pas tout se permettre
- 8 degrés